for those of you who are curious I'm
delighted some of you are I heard let me
show you this second approach it does
really work that's why lots of people
teach it but I'll show you I'll
hopefully I'll convince you why I'm not
so much of a fan okay let's come back to
the original question over here - over X
minus 3 is greater than or equal to 1
now do you remember when we did the very
first example I highlighted for you that
you have to be quite cautious with
inequalities they're not the same as
equations you can do a lot of the same
things that you do to inequalities as
you do with equations but you can't do
everything right let me give you an
example I'm gonna write this in red
because it's wrong ok if I took this guy
it's you on X minus 3 is greater than or
equal to 1 it's very very tempting
especially when you first meet these
questions to say man why do I have to
fuss around with all of this like tough
graphing and complicated asymptotes and
stuff like that I can solve this I can
solve it the same way that I solve this
guy over here right this was really easy
to do so why can't I do the same thing
with the original question well I can't
I just multiply through by X minus 3 if
you do that you'd get 2 on the left hand
side and then you get X minus 3 on the
right hand side and then you look at
this and you say well I'll add 3 to both
sides I get so you get x over here you
get 5 over here and you're like I want X
on the left hand side because that's the
normal way I would write things as I'm
switching sides unlike an equation the
inequality has Direction right so you're
like I'll switch the direction as well
and then I'm done right you're like uh
happy times I didn't need to go anywhere
near a graph isn't this a better way to
go now you can already see because we've
completed this answer this is not the
way to go it's part of the answer yes X
is less than or equal to 5 you can see
I'm going to the left here but they're
nice to stop right and this other part
of the solution isn't captured at all by
this method now that then Lisa the
question but what would why what why
does this break down like why doesn't it
work it works with equations why doesn't
work with inequalities and the answer is
because let me find another little spot
to write on over here so this is being a
little bit messy the answer is because
there are some things that you can't do
with inequalities for example
if I said to you one is less than two
none of you would bat an eyelid you'd be
like why you're wasting our time showing
us something simple mr. Wu but watch me
do something to this inequality but you
can do with an equation but you
absolutely cannot do with an inequality
I'm gonna multiply both sides of this
inequality by a number it's gonna be the
same number multiply the left by
something multiply the right by
something we do that on equations all
the time but if the number I choose is
something like say oh I don't know
negative 1 if I multiply both sides of
the equation by a negative 1 or indeed
by any other negative number you can't
write the same inequality down below
because negative 1 is not less than
negative 2 negative 1 is actually
greater than negative so this inequality
is no longer valid
now what we try to say is there's
actually a different rule for dealing
with our negative numbers on
inequalities you can't do them you just
actually have to switch around the
inequality that's how we handle these
things you can't multiply by a negative
number so long as you remember the right
thing to do with the direction of the
inequality
now the problem we're doing it over here
is because I'm not multiplying both
sides by just a number like negative 1
or negative 5 what am i multiplying both
sides by look carefully the answer is
I'm multiplying both sides by this X
minus 3 X minus 3 is not a number it's a
variable like if X changes value X minus
3 could be positive that that's why this
thing you got at the end actually is
partly right but X minus 3 can be
negative as well and if it's negative
that means you got to switch the
inequalities around and you get a whole
different question which you have to
combine with this and it's confusing
it's a bit of a mess it's why we say
don't do it like that this is a bad way
to go okay now there's a way to overcome
this and this is what the heart of the
second technique is right this the the
way to overcome this problem if I
multiply main negative is to not
multiply by negatives instead of
multiplying by X minus 3 the suggestion
is and many of you will be exposed to
this technique is multiplied instead by
X minus 3 all squared
how does this work why is this better
well when you multiply by X minus 3
remember X minus
could be could be positive but it could
be negative right and so it leads to
this problem but X minus 3 or square
this is what's ingenious about it no
matter what value you put into X right
this thing cannot be negative X minus 3
or squared cannot possibly be negative
it could be 0 but it can't be negative
because you know if I put in say 1 1
take away 3 sure enough is negative its
negative 2 but then you square it you
get 4 and everything is fine okay
so that's where this technique comes
from in some ways that is very clever
but let me show you where it leads okay
this is what you get when you take the
original question you multiply both
sides by X minus 3 all squared right it
has to be squared and then what happens
well let's let's start to solve this
thing right on the right hand side sorry
on the left hand side I should say
there's some stuff that's gonna cancel
right so this factor of X minus 3 on the
top cancels with this factor of X minus
3 on the bottom the strength of this
technique is great I no longer have
fractions to deal with so I'm like this
is immediately something that I are feel
more comfortable dealing with okay now
at this point over here you've got a
couple of choices one thing that is very
tempting is you just expand everything
then you'll have a bunch of like terms
and you just collect them and that's
that's fine I want to say that's okay
but I like to avoid that if I possibly
can like expanding is a very it's a
blunt instrument right if I can do this
in a more clever way I'd prefer to and I
notice that on the left in the right
hand sides I have common factors right
you see X minus 3 is a common factor so
what I'm gonna do is and you move this
over a little bit so I have a bit more
space on the right hand side to do my
working I am going to subtract this term
over here I'm gonna subtract it from
both sides okay so I'm going to go minus
2x minus 3
okay so I've subtracted it from that
side this inequality stays the same and
I get left with a zero over there on the
left hand side since I subtracted that
okay now again a lot of you are like
just expand just expand but I really
don't want to because look I can't you
do this in a much simpler way if I
recognize whoopsie-daisy if I recognize
that that common factor can be
factorized out right I've got an X minus
3 out the front I'm gonna write it in
long 4
just so you see it really really
obviously right X minus three times X
minus three out the front there's still
a zero over there nothing's happened to
it and then I have a look at I say well
when I take out this factor of X minus 3
from both of them right what do you get
well X minus three comes out the front
and then how many X minus 3s do you have
over here in this first term we have
this many of them X minus three of them
then when you have a look on the
right-hand side you've got a few more X
minus three you've got minus two of them
right so therefore I'm gonna get X minus
three minus two lots of X minus three
can you see how factorized that a lot of
you are kind of like what that looked me
that was confusing if that is the case
number one I'm gonna suggest you look at
it a bit longer or number two go ahead
and expand if this is really breaking
your brain but I prefer because
expanding is a process where errors
creep in so I'm trying to avoid it as
much as I can so therefore X minus three
X minus 5 this is my factorization okay
now have a look at this guy right this
guy here on the right hand side maybe I
will put on the left hand side actually
I'll put X minus three X minus five on
the left hand side since I'm reversing
this thing I'm going to reverse the
direction of the inequality less than or
equal to zero that thing on the left
hand side it's not a messy hyperbola
anymore is it it's actually a nice
comfortable parabola you can draw this
you could draw it in your sleep right
it's gonna have two intercepts one of
them is gonna be at 3 that scales
terrible sorry let's fix that
it's better one of your intercepts is
going to be at 3:00 the other intercept
is gonna be at 5:00 you've got a
parabola that goes through it and then
you say when's this parabola less than
zero when is it beneath the axis and the
answer is there it is
so you say AHA 3 is less than X is less
than 5 and I've included my boundaries
ok now at this point I hope because we
highlighted it before you're realizing
there's a problem with my solution right
this is not the solution there's an
issue with this inequality that I've
stated over here I've included the
boundary but I wasn't supposed to now in
the original way that we did this
question the hyperbolas graph kind of
told you why you weren't supposed to
include that right because you're like
you can't you can't get there you can
get close to x equals 3 but you can
never reach it because there's an
asymptote right the reason why the
Achilles heel of this technique is that
when you do this you get rid of the
asymptote you get rid of that
discontinuity but the original question
had as soon as you get to this line this
line 1 right here right see how there's
no more fractions anymore and we were
like yay no fractions it's easy to deal
with well the problem with having two
fractions is that the original question
had fractions so it has discontinuities
that my new question doesn't so the way
to overcome this for those of you who
some people love this method this is
like ah I'm at home I feel very
comfortable with this the way to
overcome that sort of shortcoming is you
look at the original question right
there and you say immediately hey wait a
second X can't equal 3 like just look at
it right as soon as you put in x equals
3 the whole thing explodes so you make a
note of this discontinuity right at the
outset and once you arrive at your final
solution which is down here in the
bottom once you arrive it there you
check it against any discontinuities
that you have determined from earlier
and you say wait on a second X can't
equal 3 even though I've said that it
can equal 3 so therefore I have to defer
to this con discontinuity and I have to
get rid of that boundary like so and now
we have the same answer that we arrived
at before so
like I said this is a very common method
in fact some textbooks even just go out
there and say this is my prescribed
technique for doing it the reason why is
because there are some there are some
nice things about it like I like getting
rid of fractions as much as the next
person but you have to be cautious you
have to see that with this question
actually the fraction part is essential
it changes your answer entirely and so
that's why my preference is actually you
know what you've got to get good at
graphing anyway so you might as well
invest in it now and use that graph and
use that technique to be able to arrive
at the right solution straight away with
no like oh my answer is right but part
of it's wrong and I need to fix it up
okay so I hope that makes sense if you
have any questions let me know
but there's both of them there for you
so that you can choose from